Sasha lives with his grandmother now in
Central Ukraine
this little boy was injured in the eye
by shrapnel from a rocket when he and
his mother left their mariopal basement
to cook food outside
the Ukrainian military looked after them
until they surrendered to the Russians
as marielpo fell
taken to a so-called filtration Camp
Russian soldiers took him away from his
mother and sent him to
russian-controlled territory in dunesque
in a cafe Sasha showed me pictures of
his mum
he doesn't know what's happened to her
but the Russians said he never see her
again
how was your mother at this stage what
was she saying
yo
mama
Sasha was saved by his grandmother after
doctors posted his picture on social
media outraged she traveled through
Russia to get him back
what was it like when you saw Sasha for
the first time
um
but the vast majority of children
weren't taken by the military in fact
they were allowed to go on trips
described as basically summer camps and
a respite from the Fighting by their
parents
this the ICC says was actually an
organized conspiracy to abduct children
Nastia stayed in touch with her mum by
sending videos from a camping Crimea
the 15 year old showed the room she
shared with two other girls how they
celebrated Christmas
one video shows them on a trip to the
seaside
on another they're at a youth club Disco
this anti-trafficking campaigners say is
the Russian authorities trying to
brainwash the children into thinking of
a new Russian life
they were also being educated on the
positives of Russian culture
when did you think I'm not going home
no
um
foreign
just like Sasha's grandmother nastia's
mum traveled through Russia jumping
through bureaucratic Hoops to get her
daughter back
this was their joyful reunion
other mothers joined her reunited with
their children and taken home
the process of finding the missing
children goes on
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine